people have had this experience before
this week
because just this week just this year
we've lost 40 people
in our city to gun violence
40 people
in just over a hundred days
part of our purpose today is to
acknowledge all of them
and the people mourning and missing
each of them
we have many wise and wonderful speakers
today who will give their perspective on
that process
because it's important that we take time
to acknowledge those losses and what
they mean for us as people
and as a community
we have to do that
so that later
we can gather our Energies
and focus on preventing these tragedies
there will be a time to act
to take steps in honor of those we've
lost
and to channel our grief and pain into
meaningful action
that day is coming
today
is to mourn
to lean on each other and support each
other
this is a time to ask each other how are
you doing
what do you need
and to really listen and really respond
to answer honestly when someone asks you
those questions
we were not meant to go through tough
times alone
and luckily we don't have to
we've seen that this week as well
in the darkness of this week I am so
grateful to the people who have brought
light and love
hope and compassion
I'm talking about the police officers
who risk their lives to save others
the medical teams who save lives on the
scene and in the hospital
the Metro 9-1-1 call takers and
dispatchers who helped get our First
Responders on the scene fast enough to
save lives
and a special thanks to the social
workers counselors Faith leaders
teachers and others who have provided
comfort and guidance to people in need
throughout all of this
thank you all
and to those who care for others please
take care of yourselves as well
we are here for you too
we have to all be here for each other
all of us
so to everyone
thank you for coming
let's continue to lean on and support
each other
in this moment of mourning and
remembering and in all of our days ahead
thank you all very much
governor beshear
[Applause]
Tommy
Josh
Juliana
Jim
Diana
fathers
mothers grandparents
children
friends
each one a child of God
these are irreplaceable kentuckians
taken far too soon by a senseless act of
violence that is certainly making me
feel heartbroken
and I think all of us torn
acts like this tear at the very fabric
of humanity of who we are and certainly
of who we want to be
it's in situations like this that we ask
how
how do we possibly move through this
I think the answer we've learned these
last several years
is together
We Are One Commonwealth United with
Louisville and the families impacted on
Monday let's love them with every single
bit of our hearts today tomorrow next
week next month next year and then the
decades to come
and let's give thanks to Our Heroes
across the city
I lost one of my best friends on Monday
but I've got two friends
and more that survived
because lmpd got there in about three
minutes
I want to thank you all
[Applause]
by now if you can and I struggle
you maybe watch that body cam footage
that shows these Heroes rushing directly
in
without pause
without regards to their own safety
because they knew lives were on the line
Heroes like lmpd officer Nicholas Wilt
who's fighting for his very life for
doing the right thing
[Applause]
and officers like CJ Galloway who after
being hit himself stayed until the
entire scene was secured
[Applause]
they did that for us
for our friends for people we care about
and for our loved ones I give them
thanks personally for their selflessness
for their bravery and I pray and I hope
everybody else joins me praying for
officer wilt's healing
we we thank our First Responders and law
enforcement agencies EMS Emergency
Management Louisville fire the Kentucky
State Police Jefferson County Sheriff's
Office Louisville Field Division and the
FBI for their support
just stopping that gunman was the first
battle
I want to thank all our Healthcare
Heroes at uofl Health that have done
their very best to keep people alive
[Applause]
Dr Jason Smith and I have been friends
for a while
we battle covet together and I know as
people of trying the very best for
officer wilt they tried their very best
for Deanna and because of their work
there are people alive here and and our
EMTs and so many others to anybody who
risks themselves Who provided that
medical attention right there that
rushed to the aid of a friend that helps
somebody get out we are so grateful God
bless you
what we need right now in one word is
love
in a world where we hear a lot of
arguments
a lot of anger where people try to
appeal to hatred and Division
how about just love
love for one another
love for even those we disagree with
answering words of anger with Words of
Love
one responsibility
I know I have is to focus and lift up my
friend Tommy
and his family
and the families and loved ones of Josh
Juliana Jim Deanna
love compassion humility empathy
they've got to be able to lead us to a
better place
well my faith is tested
and it may be even shaking I do believe
but I still believe
I believe in a loving God that one day
will explain to me how this can happen
and I believe in heaven
which means that while the body is
Mortal the soul is eternal
Tommy I will see you again and we will
see all of these incredible individuals
again
[Applause]
and I was asked earlier today what I'd
learned and it's a hard question right
now I admit that while I'm not angry I'm
empty
and I'm sad
and I just keep thinking that maybe
we'll we'll wake up
what I know is
I just wish
I'd taken an extra moment
I had an extra call
telled him how much I cared about him
and I know we are all feeling the same
but I also know that they hear us now
and that they feel our love
so when you go home from here hug your
families
call your friends
tell them how much you care about them
because one thing that I know that we
can do
is we can live for the fallen and we can
live better for them we can be better
we can be better family members better
dads better moms
we can be better community members and
we can be better people
let's commit that
to them
God bless thank you all very much
[Applause]
the next three voices that you will hear
will be that of Dr Mohammed babur a
community leader followed by Jim Ryan
the CEO of Old National Bank and Then
thirdly followed by Congressman Morgan
McGarvey Dr Muhammad babur
dear brothers and sisters
as a physician ideal death on almost
daily basis quite frequently I have to
console families after the loss of their
loved ones
I try to relate their loss sometimes as
a natural progression of human life
journey and sometimes just a will of
good Lord
but today standing next to the Sacred
Space belonging to the most articulate
compassionate and beloved Son of
Louisville Muhammad Ali I am having
tough time to find words to console the
victims
the survivors
and the loved ones
of this senseless act of violence like
you all I'm really fatigued and
frustrated on this non-stop vicious
cycle of deadly shootings in our nation
like you all I'm deadly I'm dead tired
of posting Hollow words and prayers on
the social media after each incident of
mass shooting
therefore
today I just want to plea you all and
the leaders of our great nation
that it does not matter whether you are
a Republican or a Democrat whether you
live in urban spaces or rural
communities whether you own a gun or not
please do something because we all just
want this epidemic of death to end which
is wearing down our nation
[Applause]
I know that we all bleed red I know that
we all want our children to be safe in
their schools I know that we all want
our loved ones to return home every
evening for supper so when we share same
aspirations and hopes then why we cannot
agree on finding solutions to curb this
endless cycle of violence
and
before we finally decide to do something
what it's going to take how many more
innocent children have to die how many
more fathers like our own Josh Barrick
have to make next Journey without being
there for his young two children to see
them grow up how many grandparents like
Juliana farmer have to pass away before
seeing their unborn grandchild how many
more good citizens like Jim turt Deanna
ackard and my beloved friend Tommy
Elliott have to depart this world
without
saying goodbye to live their loved ones
and leaving them behind in this madness
with unanswered questions
and
how many more parents like Todd and Lisa
sturgeon need to mourn and live while
carrying a burden of regrets on their
human hearts
how many more First Responders like
officer Nicholas Wilt have to pay price
for our Collective sin of inaction
brothers and sisters
I understand mass shootings are complex
issue which needs a multi-pronged
approach but while we Americans have
conquered space and improved human lives
with our mind-boggling medical and
scientific Innovations then why we can't
find a solution to this cancer of mass
shootings which is eating away our
children adults and seniors at a
lightning speed
so tonight
I am begging to our whole nation to do
something I am begging to presidents
Biden and Trump Senators McConnell and
Schumer speaker Osborne president
Stivers Governor Bashir and whoever is
listening out there in this universe to
do something as we cannot continue this
business as usual
[Applause]
living
living in fear is not a life that our
children and their children deserve so
please please please do something thank
you
[Applause]
good evening I can't tell you how
important
and appreciated your support is right
now
there are no adequate words to describe
what happened Monday morning
the pain the victims families are
feeling right now
there are no adequate words to describe
the Heartbreak our Old National family
is feeling
a number of our team members are here
tonight and many others are with us live
stream across our footprint
to all of you please know that we will
get through this together
[Applause]
we are here to remember and celebrate
the lives of five members of the Old
National family and to wrap our arms
around and grieve with all of those who
loved and cared for them
Josh Barrick Deanna Eckert
Tommy Elliott
Giuliana farmer
Jim Tutt
make no mistake
these were extraordinary people
they were loving generous and gifted
they poured themselves out every day
in service of others
we have come together to celebrate their
lives and also save their family members
we are here for you today
and into the future
we are also here to pray for and support
all of those who are injured
this includes the two Louisville Metro
police officers who risked their lives
to save others and it also includes
other members of our Old National family
to the families of these and Friends of
these individuals please know we are
here to pray with you and for you and to
support you in any way
I also want to share that we have been
overwhelmed with the outpouring of love
care and support from individuals and
organizations across the country
to each and every one of you thank you
on behalf of everyone at Old National I
also want to acknowledge and thank those
who have come to the aid of our OMB
family over the past three days
this includes the Louisville Metro
Police Department and the Brave and
heroic officers who are at the scene in
minutes I also want to acknowledge the
great work of the FBI
secondly I want to thank the entire
Louisville Medical Community especially
those First Responders and the staff at
the University Louisville health
you truly are heroes
[Applause]
thank you mayor Greenberg your team has
been fantastic thank you Governor
beshear the same your team and Outreach
has been absolutely incredible to each
and every one of us
I also want to thank the Red Cross for
all that you do and thank you for those
that have given the gift of life
if you're looking for a way to honor
those victims in this tragedy giving
blood is a great option
finally I want to express my gratitude
on behalf of all of us at Old National
to the entire Louisville Community
especially those religious and Mental
Health Community leaders we couldn't do
it without you
words cannot express the passion and
generous support that you've given us
and if I can offer one closing thought
it's this the greatest way we can
continue to honor everyone who has been
impacted by this tragedy is our do our
best to follow their example
we need to love one another
we need to care for one another and we
need to support one another
thank you
[Applause]
this is hard
it's just really hard
I don't know when I got to sleep last
night
I just know that when I woke up I didn't
know what day it was
because this is our city
this is our home
this is our village
it's our Lua Village
a wonderfully close-knit community
where we truly know everybody
when I was in the operating room today
with the brave doctors and nurses
they talked about knowing the people
they were trying to save
you are one degree of separation from
everybody in this town
we ask you what school you went to we
all know
we mean High School
that closeness makes this hard
it makes it hurt
and in the fog of our grief here
together
the only comfort is that closeness will
be the fabric we weave together to stay
strong
five innocent lives were taken Monday at
Old National Bank
Deanna Eckert
her daughter told me
that she and her brother
always knew they were loved
her mom was the kindest person they'd
ever met and she positively impacted
every single person she touched
Josh Barrick
just a few years younger than I am
a Louisville kid
his wife Jessica told me that he is the
center of their family
he leaves behind his wife
and two small elementary school children
who have to deal with this tragedy
we will be there for them
Jim Tutt a husband a father a
grandfather a community leader someone
who was so proud of his entire family
and who they were proud of as well
Julianna farmer
her mom Miss Bard is here with us
tonight
Miss Bard was quick to tell me
her daughter was kind she was
intelligent she raised her kids on her
own she was recruited to come back here
just a few weeks ago
to work at Old National Bank again
because they wanted her
she had a pure heart
she cared
her mom a Christian woman said I know my
child died happy
the first part of that sentence is
something no parent should ever have to
say
and I remember my friend Tommy Elliott
someone I've known for a long time a guy
who loved life
a guy because Louisville is the small
town we know it to be my wife worked
with his wife
a guy who was a friend because you know
what as much as he liked to mix it up if
Tommy told you he was for you he was for
you and he meant it
we're gonna miss Tommy
I've got us mentioned a few words about
officer wilt
who bravely ran into the line of fire
I met with his family yesterday in the
hospital
he is still in intensive care
his mom had just seen the body camera
footage
and she said I was looking at his hands
to see if he was scared
they never shook
and that's my child
whenever anybody was in trouble he ran
to help them
[Applause]
we're also praying for Siobhan Moore a
young man who tragically died minutes
later in a separate part of town a 24
year old taken from us too soon
[Applause]
this is hard
it's going to be hard
we are hurting
and we're gonna hurt for a while
and as hard as it is to read the names
of the six people we lost Monday we
would have lost more if it weren't for
the brave actions of Officer Wilt
officer Galloway the Louisville Metro
Police Department all of the First
Responders the doctors the nurses the
caretakers the state and local leaders
who helped make sure that more lives
weren't lost that day thank you
you saved lives
Louisville
this is hard
we are bent
but we are not broken
we are strong we will get through this
together we will hold each other up we
will remember and honor the lives of
those lost for years to come
[Applause]
the next three voices of reflect and
remembrance you're going to hear from
will be our Archbishop Shelton fob of
the Archbishop of Louisville then we
will be hearing from Senator Gerald Neal
whose District we have gathered in this
evening from the Kentucky State Senate
and the third voice at this time will be
from Marcus Winkler councilman president
of the Louisville Metro Council
Archbishop
my dear friends in Christ I invite you
just to listen for one moment
and what you hear
is the language of grief
and suffering
a language that we do not like but a
language that in so many ways imposes
itself upon us it's a language without
words but its presence is known the
language of grief and suffering
a language that is screaming right now
in the lives of those who lost loved
ones
a language
that is screaming right now in our
beloved city of Louisville
a language that we are all hearing and a
language that comes at us with the lie
that there is no hope
and that you face all of this alone
to the language of grief
and suffering
but do not give in to the language of
grief and suffering
because born of that is the language of
Hope and promise
born of that is the language that drives
us to learn lessons
and to make differences
and to love as we are called To Love
the language of grief and suffering will
be around for a while
but very soon because of our care for
one another
because of
Who We Are
and what we believe in and what we do
when we come together to solve problems
May the language of Hope be born amongst
us a response to that which we hear now
a language of hope that will silence the
language of grief and the language of
suffering
a language spoken by the one who
Journeys through this with us
the living and true God
who walks with us
and strengthens us and yes Comforts us
at this time
and he whispers to us the beginnings of
that language of Hope
as we continue to hear the language of
grief and suffering as it yells at us
right now
may we not give in to its deception that
there is no hope
and that there is nothing that we can do
let us hold on and Hold On Together
until the language of Hope is born
amongst us
and that language speaks loudly in our
lives in our communities and in our
hearts amen
[Applause]
I want to thank our governor our mayor
our congressman
all the leaders that have
served us well
our community leaders
my dedicated colleagues in the general
assembly
are spiritual leaders
also want to thank our Louisville
Community
and the millions of people across the
state and the nation
who are standing with us at this moment
of shock and grief
who are sending their words of love and
support
who are helping our community bear this
terrible burden in our hearts
the events on Monday were truly a shock
to the conscience and to the soul of
this city
and as we reflect on these horrific Acts
I want all of the families and friends
of those we lost
along with all the survivors
to know that our nation is with you
our hearts are aching with yours
You Are Not Alone
these sorts of senseless acts have been
heaven forbid will take place across our
nation
it includes mass shootings
single acts of vengeance
to guns that are not safely secured
this is a wide-ranging reality
gun violence comes in many forms
I shut my eyes and ask myself why
haven't we done more
why haven't we done more
this makes no sense
[Applause]
the truth is
these events are foreseeable
as painful and shocking as the news was
on Monday morning
tragically it wasn't out of the ordinary
and the lesson I glean the perspective I
find is that it is time for all of us to
do more
[Applause]
yes we must pray
yes we must reflect
but yes we must act
[Applause]
I'm certain it's possible because we're
all suffering together
we have come together
we all know things must change
we must turn this moment of sadness into
a resolve for concrete action
so let's start from the common ground
that common space of grief and Humanity
and let's be deliberate about coming
together and protecting the safety of
our community from this plague of gun
violence that is gripping our country
our children our schools our homes our
workplaces our churches
are we so entrenched in politics and
ideology that we can't take a stand to
protect those places
[Applause]
those people we care about most
[Music]
I know we can do this because we've done
it before
and I know there is a desire to find
Solutions on all sides of this issue
there can be no division on the issue of
safety
we call for everyone of Goodwill
from policy makers to Neighborhood
residents to have open honest and
serious sustained discussions with a
commitment to take effective action
to do less is unacceptable
[Applause]
make no mistake this is the time to act
this is a time to come together
with something decisive and significant
and I hope and pray
that everyone will join us in that
effort thank you
[Applause]
good evening on behalf of my colleagues
on Metro Council many of whom are with
us this evening I want to thank you all
for coming tonight to remember those
that we lost and to begin the path
towards healing
as I prepared to speak tonight I
struggled to come up with what to say
what words can one offer